look Logan I met him on tinder okay we
matched he's my prince charming and I'm
not gonna let you ruin that for me in
England that Disney Princess I realized
that maybe you don't watch CSI Miami
season four episode 24 but this guy
looks exactly like the guy that killed
three redheads in the military you can
protect me and you can sit over here
throughout my first date but do not talk
all right try not having legs
okay have Shane over here you are so
handsome
hi Jenelle nice to be sharing Shane
what's your last name
yeah it's so great to see you press and
you're like way more handsome than the
photos oh my god
and where are you from exactly like a
dress and I guess I'm from Seattle where
are you from I'm from Death Valley ah
working what else do you like to do
I let going hiking I like to get lost
what do you do for fun mostly collecting
heads of people of cabbage and
reminiscing what do you reminisce about
childhood Christmases come up collecting
heads of cabbage number one and I work
with you euthanization groups I brought
my own coffee from home why they have
come here to give yeah but I don't like
to leave my finger prints everywhere
silly
you're just so funny I'm hurting right
there okay yeah and so sorry what what
happened been hurting I hurt my arm
because I just got a new body spray can
do that I should go
cuz I've just been killing eight ball
time anyway so I had a really fun time
Shane I hope that we can there again
sometime
we picked up my place oh my god I
thought you never asked I left that I
just got you a new thing of this Queen
your artists Heba painters and your
painter
it says forty yards square but we can
check and see hey that's my best seat
Logan can't she can't it
no just 100 time I'm gonna go by taking
this with me cuz opponent